already seeing um things
escalate
quite dramatically
you know the consequences for the global
economy with the sanctions that are
being put on onto russia now by the west
xi jinping just hosted
vladimir putin at the olympics there's
reporting out there that china was you
know didn't believe the intelligence
that putin would actually invade and on
the one hand they wanted to be
responsible global power as they they
always say yet on the other hand they're
very close to russia and they pose kind
of the measures that the us has been
taking
uh particularly with financial sanctions
that have hit china as well so they're
they're caught in this trap now where
they're they're trying to have it both
ways and it's um becoming an untenable
position for them
initially china reacted um you know the
foreign ministry briefing where they it
was quite a combative
session you know they they highlighted
the fact that the russian military said
it was not attacking uh cities that it
was only going after military
installations they didn't use the word
invasion uh they blamed the us
for that we've seen them kind of come up
with a coherent message and we're not
really seeing that right now
[Music]
big question now is kind of how china
responds particularly with russia under
a severe economic stress with the the
latest sanctions
even when the u.s put sanctions on
hong kong like chinese state-run banks
would comply with the u.s sanctions
because they want access to the global
financial system so it's been the case
with
with hong kong with north korea and
other places as well even if china
is opposed to the sanctions generally
they've still complied with them to
avoid being cut off from from the global
financial system and to keep their
economy
humming along so you know the question
is what can they do um to help russia
without seeing something blow back on on
their own economy and that's kind of one
of the major things
um you know we'll be watching in the
next few weeks